[Musique]
alors ils sont là ils sont 3 il ya
frédéric bonjour frédéric bonjour merci
d'être là frédéric on l'entend bien
frédéric frédéric dites moi bonjour
bonjour voila je me sens très bien en
temps vous avez 44 on peut dire votre
âge ça va puis 44 aujourd'hui très bas
[Applaudissements]
pas de nouilles dans ce livre non pas du
tout tu pars avec une paire de babouches
derrick may
[Rires]
et en plus il a deux enfants il est
photographe à paris frédéric voilà ne
supputer pmp va nous dire pourquoi on a
également juste à côté alors je vois
rien oui d'ici comme la ville la plus
grosse havane habile feinte très bien
merci
j'aime beaucoup le petit style à pour
accélérer la ville à la mi mai merci à
corps ou allez sortez nous enlever votre
micro vous le donner à quelqu'un
ils nous ont enlevés votre étoile de
shérif également donné le donnait le
bâton élevé à estelle denis tient un
pistolet il va venir nous rejoindre
merci et vous reviendrai quand vous
serez calme et on a et on a également
comment vous appelez miam miam
merci liam alors nabil vous avez quel
âge vous avez j'ai 25 ans il sait pas
trop souffrir nabil vous en faites quoi
dans la vie sur les moteurs des ventes
animateurs des dans tout ça
dans la beauté dans la beauté va écouter
vous n'avez rien à faire ici et vous
êtes célibataire suis célibataire
absolument il est beau en parler bien
fort les chiffres vraiment pour que vous
entendez bien parce que seulement et il
y avoue fait quoi dans la vie - chasse
en direction d'accor où ça à boulogne a
juste à côté juste à côté d'accord vous
à déplacer juste ce mois là comme ça va
vite faire très bien alors je vais
démarrer par l'habile nabil alors vous
êtes vous n'aimez pas tpm pays parce
qu'on voulait des détracteurs de tpm
puis ce soir là vous allez pouvoir leur
répondre et nabil alors qu'est ce qui
vous dérange dans et pmp ce n'est plus
tôt enfin plutôt le quelques
chroniqueurs en fait donc il ya des la
rigueur alou qui vous dérange et vous
regarde vous regardez pas tes pump la
cause de ça absolument d'accord qui vous
dérange
capucine à 9 capucine alaba auparavant
vous dérangera plus quelle raison parce
qu'elle a besoin trouve qu'elle n'a pas
à l'ariana faire ici en fait c'est vrai
pourquoi
très clairement ce cas là rien à faire
ici bas vient pas de ce milieu déjà
vient pas de ce milieu je viens pas dit
si ses prises de parole sont pas
forcément sont pas forcément comment
dirais-je
on fondait d'accord vous pensez qu'il
faut que des journalistes dans tpm pc ça
non quand même pas quand même pas il y
en a beaucoup ici qui n'ont 20 qui sont
pas forcément journalistes ou issus de
vulgaires travail et non pas du tout
sauf que l non je trouve que très
clairement dans la pâte du tout sa place
là dessus il ya d'autres chroniqueurs
qui vous dérange aux vices qui vous
diront il y en a un que je peux pas
encadrer ces de leurs mots de l'or
moi je mets sur les détracteurs de cette
ligue pourquoi je m'explique on le
trouve bon c'est là où je pense que
monsieur verdez totalement me rejoindre
je le trouve ainsi qu'un but de sa
personne
trop dans le paraître dans le m'as-tu vu
tout ça et pour la petite anecdote en
fait il y à quelques quelques quelques
années maintenant je l'avais croisé à
paris
ah oui alors là où justement certains se
seraient bousculés pour une faute aux
prestigieuses ou autre je voulais
simplement lui demander que une de mes
meilleurs amis qui étaient avec moi en
l'occurrence vous voulez une photo il
saisit failli s'est même pas arrêté pour
mes images
enfin il m'a complètement largués mais
je me suis dit c'est qui celui-là quoi
c'est depuis voulez mais perdent ou
alors on est déjà à la base j'avais un
peu de mal avec le personnage mais le
fait justement enfin que qui me fasse
cette phase à son avait totalement
refroidi alors si vous nous rejoignez
c'est sûr qu'on a trois détracteurs de
tpm paix et ce jeune garçon qui est très
mignon d'ailleurs très beau gosse lui a
un problème
en fait nous alors vous regardez quand
même l'émission malgré la présence de
matthew part je la regarde de moins en
moins parce que je trouve que ça
avec le temps ça s'appelle sa valeur
d'accord mathieu que ce que vous êtes le
thème path et pmp parce qu'un jour je ne
sais pas pourquoi je suis passé à côté
toi je t'ai pas entendu et comme j'ai
entendu que la vraie info n'est fait
c'est à dire c'est que c'était un conte
et c'est comme dans l'émission faut que
tu es un petit peu de second degré aussi
mais visiblement ça doit être livré avec
un jean avec lui
et les choristes ossements honoré
mathieu mathieu larrouy m'agresse police
combien la télé que quand on veut se
faire agresser systématiquement ne
dérogeant bravo c'est une belle année
bravo
on ne vous a pas agresser il a été
justement d'asie qui t'a vu la personne
que j'ai fait il était même ça je ne les
jamais vu je ne sens pas le seul à le
dire je vais à peut arriver que parfois
on n'est pas entendus et je suis
vraiment désolé de t'avoir anthony
d'abord vu quand je suis passé à côté de
toi
voilà je suis je suis vraiment désolé
mais si pour ça parce qu'on entend pas
on est un énorme kona bas pardon tu as
raison des regards des six nations
moi j'aime beaucoup c'est parce qu'il a
dit n'est pas dynamique si la vie et
vous avez pas dans l'émission il a dit
voilà après bon il a donné mission sera
menée contre cas aussi un petit peu de
second de vie est quand même on est là
pour faire le show et tout ça n'en n'ont
alors pas lens thématique montrent un
éloge c'est pareil dans les origines est
pareil non mais mathieu ici et je le
redis encore ici personne ne joue un
rôle si vous vous jouez un rôle
bah faut le dire mais ici personne ne
joue un rôle je suis désolé on a manqué
quand même d'accord que c'est la
télévision c'est un stabilo on surligne
un peu le trait pour pour rigoler pour
s'amuser pas les doutes et bien chez moi
dans mon alors j'ai juste me dire ou es
aujourd'hui à tous ceux qui nous
regardent que je suis vraiment content
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire à moore
jouer parce que j'ai dit et je vous dis
je n'accepte pas non mais c'est pas ce
que j'ai dit bonjour je dis juste que
vous doutez bien que chez moi j'ai pas
une de leurs mots dance par exemple
c'est pour amuser à ces raisons cette
ambition là là mais regardez-moi ce qui
soit